this episode of the live files is
brought to you by the military online
game War Thunder
it was a sunny afternoon on June 24th
1947 and Kenneth Arnold was flying his
small aircraft over mineral Washington
he was heading to Yakima but took a
slight detour to look for a lost U.S
Marine Corps plane if he could find it
he could collect a nice reward flying
near Mount Rainier he spotted a shiny
object in his plane's mirror then he saw
multiple flashes of light it looked like
a group of aircraft flying in formation
but something was wrong these aircraft
didn't have tails and they were flying
faster than anything he'd ever seen
after about two minutes the objects
vanished near Mount Adams when Kenneth
landed in Yakima he immediately told his
friends and Airport staff about his
bizarre experience by the time he
reached Pendleton Oregon his story had
spread and reporters were eager to hear
it in describing the odd movement of
these objects Kenneth said it was like a
teacup saucer skipping across a lake at
that moment the term Flying Saucer was
born and the next two weeks events would
unfold that would affect every person on
Earth
and change the course of history
space panda
I wonder what you've been up to
oh hey uh I was just
are you in a fighter jet
yeah I was playing this video game War
Thunder it made me miss my old Jack day
so why I came in for turn up what's War
Thunder
is a crazy detailed immersive vehicle
combat game the most comprehensive ever
made now I'm a plane guy but there's
over 2 000 Vehicles you can play in
Dynamic combined arms PVP battles they
got tanks I like tanks
helicopter ships and armor on the planes
they get vehicles spinning over 100
years from the 1920s to now each one is
modeled down to individual components
how's it look
when I cross the tail hit the fire and
smoke effects brought me right back to
my ACN days the sound effects are
authentic and it's got this beautiful
atmospheric music
I'm in where do I play
nice so pretty much everywhere yep and
when you register on PC and use the link
play WT dot link slash the wide
files2023 you get a big free Bonus Pack
it's got multiple premium Vehicles a
premium account boosted and all kinds of
other stuff well I'll download it right
after you tell me why you called oh yeah
six full blower now yeah what a goat
rope I gotta go I'll Roger that Surfside
got my dad
fairlord
[Music]
when you drive east out of Albuquerque
on Route 40 and take the 285 South
you're in the middle of nowhere it's
sand and scrub brush for Miles take this
drive at night and the Darkness is
something you've never seen it's heavy
and penetrating and unsettling if you're
not used to it and summer storms in the
New Mexico desert are also something
unique heat lightning can tear through
the sky for hours lighting up the
landscape all the way to the Horizon
July 1st 1947 was one of the worst
lightning storms in years that same
night the Army Airfield outside of
Roswell have been tracking strange radar
blips same with the nearby White Sands
Proving Ground a missile base that have
been testing German V2 Rockets since the
end of the war the nuclear testing
facility at the Alamogordo bombing range
was also tracking the objects the blips
were moving too fast to be aircraft some
blips would disappear off the radar
screen then reappear a few seconds later
this was a major concern the 509th that
Roswell was an elite unit the only unit
responsible for deploying Atomic weapons
finally technicians took the radar
equipment apart to check for
malfunctions they couldn't find any the
objects continued to zip around the area
for hours Dan wilmett and his wife were
on their porch watching the lightning
storm when a bright oval object zipped
over their house and disappeared over
the horizon moments later the object
streaked over Steve Robinson's truck as
he was making deliveries he tracked the
object to the Horizon moving faster than
any plane he'd ever seen over the next
few nights local sheriff George Wilcox
received dozens of calls about objects
in the sky he hadn't seen anything
himself so he told the folks it was
probably lightning or planes from the
nearby Air Base but then Mack Brazil a
local Rancher came into the office Mack
told the sheriff he had come across a
debris field on his Ranch in Corona New
Mexico at first he thought it was plane
wreckage but the material was like
nothing he'd ever seen he even brought a
few pieces to show the sheriff in the
back of Max pickup were pieces of metal
that look like aluminum foil but much
thinner it was also much stronger and
lighter and strangest of all even though
you can bend or crumple the metal as
soon as you released it it would revert
back to its original shape the sheriff
called Roswell Army Airfield just
outside of town and the matter was
assigned to an Army intelligence officer
major Jesse Marcel Brazil took Marcel
back to the debris site and the two
gathered up more pieces of material from
the crashed object on Tuesday Morning
Marcel took the material to the base
commander Colonel William Blanchard
later that day Walter Haught the base's
public information officer issued a
press release that was picked up by
newspapers and radio stations all over
the country well let me guess the press
release said they deny everything nope
United States Army press release said
we found a UFO yes
[Music]
Headline Edition July 8 1947 the Army
Air Forces has announced that a flying
disc has been found and is now in the
possession of the army army officers say
the missile found sometime last week has
been inspected at Roswell New Mexico and
sent to right field Ohio for further
inspection
the report was national news it was the
biggest story in the country late this
afternoon a bulletin from New Mexico has
suggested that the widely publicized
mystery of the flying saucers May soon
be solved Army Air Force officers
reported that one of the strange discs
had been found and inspected sometime
last week
but it was only the biggest story for a
day just a few hours after the news
broke the Army retracted it then General
Roger Ramey at Fort Worth Army Airfield
ordered major Marcel to personally
deliver the wreckage to him in Texas a
few hours after they landed General
Ramey held a press conference where
aluminum foil and pieces of wooden
debris were spread out in front of
photographers and newspaper men Remy
with Marcel and Colonel Thomas Dubose
backing him up insisted that the whole
UFO thing was a mistake that the debris
was from a weather balloon and that's
all there was to the story Mac brasel
the Rancher who found the wreckage also
changed his story he said he regretted
coming forward and that the debris was
just rubber strips tin foil some paper
and balsa wood Marcel in front of the
press backed him up on this and said
simply we went back to the ranch and
found a few more patches of tinfoil and
rubber General Ramey went back to his
normal duties and the whole matter was
officially dropped headlines again
spread throughout the country that the
flying disc was nothing more than a
weather balloon hey they really took the
air out of this story yeah
see after
after everyone seemed to move on the
Flying Saucer craze cool down and the
country forgot about Roswell
oh not even close the men at the press
conference were the famous photos were
taken were Men of Honor if they're given
orders they follow them but as they grew
old they remained Men of Honor but there
were no more orders to follow all they
had left to follow was their conscience
so these Men of Honor
they started telling the truth
[Music]
Dr Bob Wood was an aerospace engineer
with a long and distinguished career he
worked at Sikorsky Lockheed Hughes and
McDonald Douglas he taught courses at
Georgia Tech UCLA Caltech and USC Dr
Wood was very well known so it's easy to
find his work history but there is a
hole in Dr Wood's resume from 1968 to
1970. during that time wood worked on a
secret study for McDonnell Douglas he
was given a huge budget to find out if
UFOs were real or not one of the first
people Dr Wood recruited for this
project was a young scientist also
working at McDonnell Douglas Stanton R
Friedman Friedman was a nuclear
physicist by trade but also dabbled in
UFO investigation at the end of their
18-month study they determined that UFOs
were real and worth investigating Dr
Wood was invited to present his findings
to Congress but knew this would hurt his
career so he declined but Dr Friedman
took a different path after working on
the UFO study for McDonnell Douglas
Friedman began giving speech is on the
subject to Civic groups and scientific
organizations UFOs had become his
passion so he left the Aerospace
industry changed his nickname to the
Flying Saucer physicist and begun
investigating UFOs full time but even as
late as the mid-1970s Stenton Friedman
had never heard of the Roswell incident
in 1978 Friedman heard about it from a
television producer the producer Bill
Allen told Friedman that he was ham
radio buddies with Jesse Marcel when
Friedman learned that Marcel was the
intelligence officer at a base that
actually handled the wreckage from a UFO
crash Friedman wanted to meet him and
the story of the Roswell incident takes
a wild turn
[Music]
we found a piece of metal
uh about about a foot and a half to two
feet wide and about about two three feet
long sounds like you had nothing in your
hands it wasn't any thicker than the
foil out of a pack of cigarettes
but the the thing about that got me
isn't you couldn't even bend it you
couldn't embed at it even with a
sledgehammer would bounce off it
so I knew that I had never seen anything
like that before and as of now I don't
know what it was
that doesn't sound like the material
from a weather balloon
they took pictures of course they had a
whole flock of microphones there they
wanted me to they wanted some comments
from me but I wasn't at dribble to do
that
so all I could do is keep my mouth shut
and general Raymond is the one who
discussed or told the newspapers
I mean the newsman what it was and to
forget about it it was nothing more than
a what the observation balloon
we both knew differently
Jesse Marcel was in charge of
intelligence for the only Atomic unit in
the world he wasn't going to go against
orders but before he went to the base
with the wreckage and received the keep
quiet order he stopped at home first
there he showed the pieces to his wife
and his son Jesse Jr in 1942 review it
was a little stuff in the back seat and
in the trunk area
and in an effort to
try to piece it together
the pieces weren't just metallic scraps
there was a small I-beam that had some
kind of writing on it that Jesse and his
father described as hieroglyphics they
even had the piece recreated and that's
when I saw the the writing or the
symbols of some sort I thought at first
this is hieroglyphics or some kind of
writing like that it certainly looked
alien to me
Marcel was extremely familiar with all
kinds of aircraft including top secret
craft being deployed from Roswell Air
Base this wreckage didn't come from
anything he recognized
it was not anything from this Earth that
I'm quite sure of
because I was eager to tell us almost I
was familiar with just about all
materials used in aircraft and in our
air travel this is nothing like that
Colonel Thomas Dubose retired as a
brigadier general which general Ramey's
Chief of Staff he also posed for
pictures at the press conference he
confirmed in multiple interviews that
the weather balloon story was a lie
it was a cover Story the balloon part of
it
as the story that's to be given to the
press and that is dipped and anything
else forget it
General Clements McMullen in Washington
DC called Dubose and gave him three
orders one get the press off our backs
two send some of the wreckage to
Washington and three never speak of this
again not to General Ramey not to anyone
so he didn't
as Deputy to to George Kenny and he in
turn responsible to the president this
is the highest priority you can exit and
you will say nothing in that vision of
it and
then Jesus that's in the matter in Chief
and and he forgot about it
well Friedman kept interviewing
Witnesses kept releasing articles and
kept speaking publicly about Roswell and
how he believed it was a cover-up
throughout the 80s and 90s the military
either said the weather balloon story
was true or they said nothing at all but
then in 1993 something very unexpected
happened after a lot of public pressure
the military issued a report about the
Roswell incident it turned out that
Friedman was right the debris showed to
the press in 1947 and the whole weather
balloon Story the military admitted it
was a lie
foreign
[Music]
1993 a U.S congressman from New Mexico
Stephen Schiff launched an inquiry into
the Roswell incident Congress directed
The Air Force to conduct an internal
investigation to uncover any documents
they might have in 1995 the Air Force
released its findings in the Roswell
report fact versus fiction in the New
Mexico desert the report concluded that
the material recovered by Jesse Marcel
from Mark Brazos Ranch in 1947 was not
from a regular weather balloon the
wreckage was actually from a super
secret program called project Mogul
project Mogul was a military
surveillance program balloons equipped
with acoustic sensors were launched to
high altitudes to listen for the
signatures of Russian atomic bomb tests
so why did some of the men at the air
base think this was UFO well because
they were never told about project mogul
to attempt to limit unauthorized
disclosure the Air Force employed a
security mechanism known as
compartmentation
compartmentation controlled access to
classified information by dispersing
portions of the research among several
facilities and institutions
each participating entity received only
enough information necessary to
accomplish its assigned tasks
in the case of Mogul only a small circle
of Air Force officers received the
intimate details that linked together
these unrelated research projects
okay but these were highly trained
military personnel they couldn't
recognize a surveillance balloon well
according to the Air Force report no
they couldn't
although members of the 509th possessed
high-level clearances they were not
privy to the existence of Mogul their
job was to deliver nuclear weapons not
to detect them
and to be perfectly clear the
investigators found no evidence of a UFO
the Air Force research found absolutely
no indication that what happened near
Roswell in 1947 involved any type of
extraterrestrial spacecraft
uh it's just kind of like when the FBI
investigates its
itself and finds they did nothing wrong
it's exactly like that yeah the report
didn't sit well the balloon story sounds
like it's full of hot air yeah yeah
okay so I couldn't help it go on the Air
Force said that the wreckage wasn't a
flying saucer they said it was a secret
balloon what they didn't really address
was the fact that they lied to the
American people and put a bunch of fake
balloon wreckage on display for the
Press so in 1997 the Air Force issued
another report they had a lot of
questions to answer like what happened
to all the records from 1947. wait what
do you mean
records such as Finance and Accounting
supplies buildings and grounds and other
General administrative Matters from
March 1945 through December 1949 and
raaf outgoing messages from October 1946
through December 1949 were destroyed
[Music]
the document disposition form did not
properly indicate the authority under
which the disposal action was taken
records are good and
but the question people really wanted to
be answered was what happened to the
alien bodies recovered from the second
secret crash site another crash with
bodies
My Sharona
yes there have been ET visitation there
have been crashed craft
there have been
material and bodies recovered
and there is some group of people
somewhere
that
may or may not be associated with
government at this point but certainly
were at one time
that have this knowledge
first Pub public crash site was a few
miles south of Corona New Mexico but
there was a second crash site and
according to eyewitnesses whistleblowers
and leaked documents here's what
happened the summer of 1947.
in a few months leading up to the
Roswell incident there were over 300 UFO
sightings over the New Mexico desert
these were witnessed by local residents
and military personnel on Friday July
4th two alien ships were flying over
Corona New Mexico why they were there is
unclear but best guess is they were
surveying White Sands Missile Range back
then White Sands was the Alamogordo
bombing and Gunnery Range it's about 35
miles Southeast of Socorro New Mexico
and was the location of Trinity the
first time the human race deployed a
nuclear weapon that evening there was an
especially violent thunderstorm
lightning filled the sky the alien ships
unprepared for and unshielded from
lightning experience and Equipment
failure while flying in a tight
formation they Collide Rancher Mac
brasel hears a tremendous Thunderclap
but it's different from the rest of the
Thunder others in the area report
similar phenomena
what phenomena
and you may continue
at 11 27 p.m military radar
installations all reports seeing the
objects then they pulse and vanish they
suspect a crash Jim Ragsdale and his
friend Trudy are camping in the area
they see a bright flash of light and
hear a roaring sound that passes
overhead then something big strikes the
ground nearby
several archaeologists including W Curry
Holden or working a dig near Roswell
they stumble across the impact site
where the object is crashed one of them
heads to the closest phone to tell
Sheriff George Wilcox they found a
crashed aircraft Wilcox calls the local
fire department to alert them about the
crash the site is about 35 miles north
of Roswell the Roswell Fire Department
escorted by members of the Roswell
Police Department's respond these are
among the first civilians to visit the
impact site at 5 30 a.m the military
knowing the approximate location of the
saucer crash move in with a carefully
selected team to recover the craft the
soldiers find civilians already on site
Bay Area is secured and the civilians
are escorted off only those with the
highest clearance are allowed near the
center of the impact guards are posted
facing out the site is cleaned and
secured in six hours five alien bodies
are recovered the aliens are described
the same way by many witnesses about
four feet tall large heads large eyes no
ears no nose only nostrils and small
mouths they had pale skin at first the
bodies appeared to be without clothes
but they were actually wearing very
tight-fitting suits the bodies are
covered by sheets then placed in
lead-lined body bags John mcboyle a
reporter for ksws radio in Roswell
attempts to access the site he calls the
station a report seeing a crushed dish
pan-like object and a large military
presence Lydia sleppy from the parent
station in Albuquerque tries to
broadcast his report Slappy receives a
call from the FBI and is ordered not to
broadcast Melvin F Brown who is on guard
duty at the impact site has been ordered
to not look under the tarp but the
moment that everyone's back is turned he
does he sees the bodies of the alien
flight crew he described them as small
with large heads and pale skin nearby
Mac brazzell discovers a large debris
field he heads to the home of his
closest neighbors Floyd and Loretta
Proctor he shows them a little sliver of
material that he can neither burn nor
cut the Proctors suggests he shows the
sheriff he agrees and gathers pieces of
the wreckage and heads home for the
night I remember he said something about
that you could crumple it up and it
could
not back out military bases along the
west coast put fighters on standby in
case more flying discs are seen bases in
Oregon and Washington have planes
equipped with gun cameras they're put on
Airborne Alert in Roswell for a
conference C Bertram Schultz a
paleontologist sees a large military
presence on Highway 285. he doesn't
realize until later why so many soldiers
were there local mortician Glenn Dennis
Contracting with the air base receives
an odd request for small caskets and
later encountered unusual debris at the
hospital while aiding an injured Airmen
Dennis is then confronted by officers
who tell him he's seen and heard nothing
they say quote if he opens his mouth
they will be picking his bones out of
the sand
and it said let Pastor you don't go and
start any rumors and Roswell nothing
happened out here
and he said if you do you you know it'd
be real serious problems and then
so I just
being as
my character was at that time I said I'm
a survey and you can go to hell
and that's where he said you may be the
one going to help and then that's when
he really told me he said somebody'd be
picking your bones out and saying if you
do that
back at the crash site the bodies are
sealed into a long crate which is taken
to a hangar and left overnight the crate
is guarded by military police who are
ordered not to approach it Melvin Brown
is once again standing guard Brown's
commanding officer approaches and says
come on brownie let's have a look inside
but there's nothing to see because
everything has been packed and created
ready for shipment to where the soldiers
have no idea
William Woody and his father try to
drive out toward the area where they'd
seen the object coming down but the
roads are blocked the side roads off
Highway 285 from Vaughn and to the West
are guarded by military police who allow
no one to pass Mac brasel gets up early
and drives to Roswell about 75 miles
away he stops at the office of sheriff
George a Wilcox Wilcox is excited about
the find and notifies the military at
Roswell Army Airfield while waiting for
the Military Officers to arrive Wilcox
sends two of his deputies to the ranch a
reporter named Frank Joyce contacts the
Sheriff's Office to inquire about any
interesting events Wilcox directs him to
Brazil Colonel William Blanchard in
charge of the 509th Bomb Group instructs
air intelligence officer Jesse a Marcel
to investigate Marcel visits the
sheriff's office he interviews Brazil
examines the material and then decides
to visit the ranch himself Marcel
returns to the base taking some debris
with him and reports his findings to
Blanchard convinced they have something
highly unusual possibly of Soviet origin
Blanchard alerts his superiors Marcel
comes back to the Sheriff's Office with
counterintelligence agent Captain
Sheridan Cavett they take Brazil back to
his Ranch and inspect the debris field
following orders from General Clements
McMullen Blanchard obtains more debris
from the Sheriff's Office it's sealed
and transported to Fort Worth Army
Airfield where Colonel Thomas Dubose
receives it for onward transport to
Washington D.C after Marcel and Cabot
leave with Brazil the two deputies
returned to say they didn't find the
debris field but they did find a burned
area in one of the pastures where sand
had been turned to Glass and blackened
it looked as if something circular had
touched down at Fort Worth Army Airfield
the Bose and Colonel Allen D Clark
received the debris and prepare to fly
it to Washington DC and General McMullen
because of the distance to the ranch
over roads that are less than adequate
Brazil Marcel and Cavett don't arrive
until after dark they stay at an Old
Ranch House nearby and wait for daylight
a special flight departs for Andrews
Airfield in Washington DC at 2 am
carrying the debris and the bodies
Brazil guides two Military Officers to
the crash site the debris is thin as
paper but incredibly sturdy the metal
paper reminds them of tin foil they can
crumple it but the metal immediately
returns to its original shape Mac brasel
is becoming inundated with media
requests so Walt Whitmore Frank Joyce's
boss at kgfl arranges to hide Brazil at
his own home Marcel and Cavett combed
the fields perimeter and surrounding
areas they collect debris and at dusk
begin the trip back to Roswell later in
the afternoon civilian reports come in
regarding a second crash site Lieutenant
General Nathan e Twining is commander of
the air material command at right field
Ohio AMC worked closely with industry
Partners research labs and other
government agencies to advance Aviation
Technology the general Alters his plans
and flies into Alamogordo Army Field
Alamogordo Army Field also known as
Holloman Air Force Base is located
approximately 82 miles Southwest of
Roswell New Mexico a few years later a
film would be leaked from Holloman
showing UFOs landing on the base General
Carl spatz commander of all Army Air
Forces tells reporters that he knows
nothing about the flying discs or the
plans from various local units to search
for them Walt Whitmore senior who asked
Brazil to stay the night in Roswell at
his home now brings in kgfl news that
evening the station owner and newsman
Judd Roberts records an interview with
Brazil the interview is scheduled to be
broadcast the following morning Roberts
didn't know it at the time but that
broadcast would never happen
foreign
[Music]
Marcel stops at his house on the way to
the base waking his wife and son they
examine the debris on the kitchen floor
believing it to be a flying saucer they
loaded into the car with his son's help
at 6am Marcel and Cavett informed
Blanchard about what they've seen
Blanchard ordered guards to secure the
debris field denying access to
unauthorized individuals Blanchard
contacts Eighth Air Force Headquarters
dismissing the possibility of material
being from a Soviet device the message
is relayed up the chain of command to
SAC headquarters during a staff meeting
at 7 30 am the debris is discussed
samples of the wreckage are examined but
no one can identify it the main concern
is whether to disclose the discovery to
the public General Ramey proposes a plan
to divert attention away from the
incident Walt Whitmore at kgfl receives
a phone call from the FCC in Washington
he's told not to air the interview with
Mac brasel if he does the station will
lose its broadcast license later Senator
Dennis Chavez chairman of the Senate
appropriation committee called Whitmore
to strongly advise him to do as he was
instructed Blanchard confers with higher
headquarters Jesse Marcel is ordered to
Fort Worth Mack brazel the ranch Foreman
who first discovered the debris field
was arrested and detained by the U.S
army he remained in custody for four or
five days Brazil was denied access to a
phone was given an army physical and was
subjected to rigorous questioning and
intimidation while under arrest Sheriff
Wilcox returns to the crash site with
two deputies military police deny them
access at 11AM Colonel Blanchard
announces the recovery of a flying disc
Lieutenant Walter Haught distributes the
press release to radio stations and
newspapers at 2 26 PM the story hits the
AP wire it reads the Army Air Force is
here today announced a flying disc had
been found the base receives so many
calls that it becomes difficult to
access an outside line four minutes
after this at 2 30 PM Colonel Blanchard
officially goes on leave the he actually
returns to the site to oversee
additional cleanup he deploys techniques
learned from the less reported UFO crash
that occurred in Missouri in 1941. at 3
pm Marcel is told that he's going to
Fort Worth with the wreckage only a few
packages are loaded onto the plane one a
triangular package about two feet long
is wrapped in brown paper the other
three are about the size of shoe boxes
they're so light that it feels as if
there's nothing in them the special
flight of B-29 takes off for the Fort
Worth Army Airfield Marcel arrives in
Remy's office with some of the debris
the general wants to see where the
debris was found Marcel accompanies him
to the map room once raymie is satisfied
they walk back to the General's office
but the debris is gone and its place is
a ripped apart weather balloon scattered
on the floor at 4 30 PM General Roger
Amy commander of the 8th Air Force and
Blanchard's supervising officer
presented to the Press an alternate
story he claimed the Army had recovered
a high altitude balloon War are an
officer Irving Newton is ordered from
the weather office at the Fort Worth
Army Airfield to Remy's office Newton in
front of a small number of reporters and
officers identifies the wreckage on the
office floor as a balloon he's
photographed and sent back to his
regular duties the Press takes
photographs of Jesse Marcel General
Ramey and Thomas Dubose with the balloon
at 6 17 PM the FBI sends a teletype
message from the Dallas office to FBI
director J Edgar Hoover telling him that
a balloon is responsible for the reports
the message disputes General Ramey's
announcement to the Press at 7 30 PM the
AP breaks the news that the Roswell
flying disc was a balloon raymie appears
on a radio station and confirms this a
few hours later an unscheduled flight
arrives an officer hands over more
sealed boxes of wreckage at 11 59 PM the
photographs are transmitted to New York
for wide distribution but a small hiccup
in the official story during the entire
process rainy held a memo in his right
hand and in the photos the text is very
blurry but by the early 2000s software
had improved to the point that enhancing
the memo became feasible but to do this
you'd need the original negatives right
from the camera if they still existed
well Stanton Friedman looked into this
and it turned out the negatives did
still exist so he bought them and had
them analyzed so can you read the words
most of the words yes what's it say it
doesn't mention
it sure does
[Music]
Stanton Friedman spent a lot of money to
recover the original photographic
negatives from the press conference
where the weather balloon was made
public the negatives and prints made
from them were subjected to multiple
levels of analysis in at least one of
the photographs the front face of the
memo is clearly visible early analysis
showed that there were several words
that could be deciphered which had
electrifying implications the words
urgent victims wreck and the name of Air
Force General Hoyt Vandenberg came
through very clearly also references to
a disc to be shipped by B-29 which did
happen the message then seems to imply
that they should mistake the meaning of
the story it then suggests sending out
public relations officers with weather
balloons that this would work if photos
were used and demonstrated to the Press
it did work
morning newspapers report that the
Flying Saucer near Roswell is a weather
device second site cleanup resumes at
Sunrise to ensure civilians don't
stumble upon the Airfield at 8 AM
members of the first Air transport unit
load crates into c-54s armed guards
watch as three or four aircraft are
loaded for transport to Kirtland Air
Base and then on to Los Alamos Los
Alamos was and might still be the most
secure military facility in the world
Colonel Blanchard personally takes hot
to building 84 Hangar P3 which is
heavily guarded both inside and out
inside hot observes the recently
recovered object 12 to 15 feet long six
feet high resembling an egg with a
metallic surface no windows portholes
Wings tail section or landing gear were
visible he sees a couple of bodies under
a canvas tarp they have large heads and
are child sized there's been so much
that has been brought full
by legitimate people
that there can be something to it and
apparently that what it wasn't something
that
planted out there in the desert
and firmly
more wreckage arrives at the base boxed
into crates of various sizes and shapes
at noon a crate guarded by MPS is moved
to bomb pit number one it's unusual for
anything other than weapons to be stored
there in Roswell Floyd Proctor and Lyman
Strickland spot Mac brasel escorted by
Military Officers ignoring their
attempts to communicate which is strange
photographer Robin Adair receives a call
from the main office in New York
instructing him to head to Roswell
immediately he flies over the sites he
sees troops vehicles and military police
covering large areas a sealed unmarked
wooden crate is brought out and loaded
into a B-29 tail number 7301 Bound for
Fort Worth it's guarded by six armed MPS
never allowing it out of their sight on
their military escort Mac Brazil is
taken to the offices of the Roswell
Daily Record where he provides reporters
with a news story later reporter Frank
Joyce points out that this new story is
much different than his original account
Brazil funds that it would be bad for
him if he didn't tell the news story at
8pm the B-29 flight crew is back again
they were not debriefed but are told
that they have flown the General's
Furniture to Fort Worth they're
cautioned not to tell anyone including
their families about the flight as far
as anyone is concerned the flight never
happened
at the debris field and impact site
cleanup is intense no debris remains and
there's no sign they were ever there
military personnel returned to sheriff
Wilcox office and asked for a box of
debris that he'd been storing Wilcox
surrenders it without protest
[Music]
the debriefings of all Witnesses are
underway participants are taken into a
room in small groups and told that the
recovery is a highly classified event
everyone is to forget that it ever
happened the military warned civilians
around Roswell that they can never talk
about what happened in some cases the
Witnesses are threatened with death
should they ever speak to anyone over
the next few years the military
continued to search for and even find
more debris from the crash sites but
they stonewalled long enough that the
public lost interest Roswell was still
talked about in local UFO groups and
zines but those were considered Fringe
but in 1978 Stanton Friedman brought the
Roswell incident to the mainstream in
1980 Bill Moore and Charles berlitz guy
yep that guy they wrote the Roswell
incident which sold a lot of copies
Roswell was covered on TV shows like
Unsolved Mysteries and in search of and
later was featured prominently on the
X-Files by the 1990s everyone had heard
of Roswell which forced the Air Force to
released that report in 1995. this
brings us back to the second Air Force
report released in 1997 and in this
report we finally learned what happened
to the bodies
in 1997 the Air Force released another
report about Roswell it was called the
Roswell report case closed this report
rehashed the project Mogul balloon
explanation of the wreckage it spent
some time trying to discredit Witnesses
and UFO investigators and it explained
why they were eyewitness reports of
bodies the Air Force said these
recovered alien bodies were actually
Crash Test Dummies used in high altitude
parachute tests oh this is gonna be good
the project was codenamed Operation High
Dive High Dive dropped hundreds of
dummies from various Heights to see what
kind of Falls could be survivable I
study aliens everyone saw with dummies
that's the word I said they used four
foot tall dummies with big heads huh
nope the dummies were six feet tall but
some were discovered burned so their
limbs were shorter
um or they were damaged damage to the
dummies included loss of heads arms legs
and fingers this detail dummies with
missing fingers appears to satisfy
another element of the research profile
aliens with only four fingers
uh you know I think the real dummies are
the people who wrote this report yeah I
would agree that this is not as
satisfying an explanation as the Air
Force thinks it is okay okay let's say
the Air Force is telling the truth which
they're not but let's just say they
really dropped dummies all over the
desert okay
dummies were confused with I can't
believe I'm even saying it the dummies
were confused with four foot tall aliens
right why not just tell us that in the
other report oh because operation high
jump the super secret high altitude
dummy dropping project it didn't start
until 1953. six years after the Roswell
crash uh is this a joke nope uh they're
talking about 1947. well you're talking
about dummies used in the uh in the 50s
almost a decade later well I'm afraid
that's a problem that we have with time
compression
oh did he say time compression yeah
that's Air Force speak four people got
the dates wrong are you punking me well
what is this the report even quotes an
eyewitness named Gerald Anderson who
found bodies that he said look like
plastic dolls incredible witness I don't
know maybe Gerald was a very intelligent
and observant five-year-old precocious I
think they call it they quoted a
five-year-old witness they did but to be
fair Gerald was 55 when they interviewed
him okay okay let me get this straight
the interview a 55 year old man who
tells him what he saw 50 years ago when
he was five that's right geez I haven't
seen an investigation this sloppy sensor
oh well since every FBI investigation in
the last five years yeah it wasn't
convincing this is a common government
cya technique you assert the outcome
then you have your team of investigators
and experts fill in the details that
eventually arrive at your desired
outcome no matter how ridiculous the
details are Oh you mean like a bat Kebab
from a wet Market in the middle of
nowhere well that theory is still being
debated yeah
stay focused
that's only fair that we present all
sides of the Roswell story now the
timeline I went through earlier is all
from witness accounts and sworn
affidavits there are a lot of accounts
that I didn't cover because I couldn't
corroborate them but even the witness
reports I did Cover aren't perfect I've
seen videos and books and articles say
that there are as many as 600
eyewitnesses who've come forward saying
they saw ships and debris and bodies now
maybe that's true but I can only find
seven almost every witness account comes
from a friend or a spouse or a child or
grandchild of a witness and other
Witnesses have had trouble with their
stories Loretta Proctor who saw the
debris when Matt Brazil brought it to
her house said they couldn't burn the
metal they tried bending it and cutting
it and they couldn't do it that's a new
story her earlier story mentions nothing
about debris in fact she specifically
said she never saw debris of any kind
Lydia sleppy was the teletype operator
who claimed the FBI interrupted her
broadcast and ordered her to stop and
there is no evidence of this at all oh
yeah but a lot of evidence has
disappeared in this case that's true but
I still would have liked to have seen a
memo about the broadcast and it's just
not there Melvin Brown was the guard who
said he saw bodies on two different
occasions once the crash site and once
while guarding the hangar the truth is
his story comes from his daughter
Beverly who only mentioned Roswell many
years after her father died it doesn't
mean it's not true he was guiding
something yeah but he wasn't a guard he
was a cook oh uh Cooks don't God top
secret military facilities
the alien's Frozen right so he he was
probably God in the freezer in the
kitchen remember I said it's a
government technique to start with an
outcome then try to find facts to fit
that's that yeah I'll Chuck this one up
to a maybe major Jesse Marcel is one of
my favorite Witnesses but take his story
with a whole lot of salt he used to
exaggerate his military record quite a
bit he overstated his commendations his
Rank and his credentials he claimed he
was a pilot and shot down five enemy
aircraft he even said he flew the UFO
wreckage himself but Marcel wasn't a
pilot there's an evaluation report from
General raymie himself who said Marcel
was a competent officer but quote since
this officer is not a rated pilot his
Assumption of the position of Commanding
General is not a consideration Marcel
was an intelligence officer before that
an administrative assistant and before
that a photo interpretation and visual
aids officer he never flew he also
didn't have a degree in physics which he
had claimed during some interviews in
2020 Marcel's grandchildren supposedly
found his diary where he documented
everything he saw this was both exciting
and suspicious Marcel gave interviews
for 20 years and never mentioned a diary
turned out he didn't write it and we
don't know who did so his story just got
Messier Colonel Thomas Dubose was one of
the men photographed with Marcel with
the weather balloon not only did the
Bose say the wreckage was not switched
but he would get pretty annoyed when
asked about it he said the wreckage in
the photos is the same wreckage that
Marcel brought from Roswell glenden is
the mortician gets a lot of things wrong
and I left out most of his testimony
because a big piece of his story is how
he had a friend who was a nurse on the
base they had lunch one day she showed
him a drawing of an alien body then she
ended up dead but this never happened
then there is Walter hot the public
relations officer who saw the craft and
the bodies he gave a sworn affidavit to
be released after his death signed and
witnessed by a notary and given after a
doctor pronounced him of sound mind a
lot of the Roswell story comes from his
affidavit that he gave in 2002 but he
was interviewed in 2000 and he had
trouble remembering everything his
affidavit however was clear and detailed
turns out the affidavit was written by a
UFO author based on interviews with hot
hot reviewed it didn't make any changes
and signed it now does that mean the
affidavit is wrong no it could be 100
true but in every story about Roswell
it's presented as hot's words when it
was not it's very possible that when he
signed the document he didn't understand
what it was
but I've seen the interviews with him
and he did say everything was true so
he's a tricky one Colonel Blanchard did
go on leave right after the crash but he
didn't oversee any cleanup operation he
went on a two-week vacation with his
wife to Santa Fe sure these records
could have been falsified but there's
proof that he was with the governor
during this time so a lot of witnesses
do change their story over time and
that's to be expected it's 50 60 70
years but true believers Cherry Picked
the best stories and throw away all the
rest the truth is we will never really
know what happened in Roswell in 1947.
the records are gone the Witnesses are
dead and with all due respect UFO
researchers they only write one side of
the story skepticism doesn't sell it
doesn't I believe something did happen
out there but whether it was a secret
military program or an alien crash site
I can't be sure well this turned out to
be a down butts go on in 2013 a document
was found in the FBI archives it's
written by Guy title special agent in
charge of the Washington office it
stated March 22nd 1950 and the title is
information concerning flying saucers an
investigator for the Air Forces stated
that three so-called flying saucers had
been recovered in New Mexico they were
described as being circular in shape
with raised centers approximately 50
feet in diameter each one was occupied
by three bodies of human shape but only
three feet tall dressed in metallic
cloth of a very fine texture
that was sent to J Edgar Hoover the
director of the FBI who declined to
pursue it which
the one final twist to the Roswell story
and it's a Twist that needs its own
video and if you want me to cover it let
me know in 1972 a witness came forward
with new information information that
was always hinted at but now we have a
lot more details turns out one of the
aliens recovered from Roswell stayed in
Los Alamos until 1952. still in the
freezer no he was alive and he had a lot
to say
fairlord this is Surfside time to bring
it in all right hang on you're excited I
gotta do this thing thanks again to our
sponsor War Thunder use the link in the
description to join now and get your
free bonus pack and premium goodies all
right it's fair Lord here I'm coming
home
thanks so much for hanging out with us
today my name is AJ there's hecklefish
this has been the y-files and if you had
fun or learn anything do Heckle fish a
favor like subscribe share comment that
stuff really helps us out and makes him
so happy and like most topics we cover
on the channel today's was recommended
by you so if there's a story you'd like
to see or learn more about go to the
yfiles.com tips and if you'd like to
join a great Community Check out the
Wi-Fi's Discord it's free to join
there's thousands of people on there and
it's a lot of fun now special thanks to
our patrons who make this channel
possible you guys are amazing and we
could not do this without you and if
you'd like to support the channel
consider becoming a member on patreon
for as little as three bucks a month you
can keep the Y files going and you get
all kinds of perks or buy something from
the Wi-Fi store hello
you can buy a 12 hecklefish plushie fish
style yeah or t-shirts show to people I
don't really
fine
[Music]
adorable well that's one way to describe
it
well that's gonna do it until next time
be safe be kind and know that you are
appreciated
Hallelujah
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]